thank you
[Music]
welcome everybody to a very special
episode of careful boys today we have
Miss geo with us
also we have Ken over there with Colleen
hey Nick and I believe all women sector
because it is to be put in a dustpan
we're in the corner huh they're trash
this is that means it's garbage but
what's what's garbage
that side
[Music]
camera like a one-two punch over there
so you just came from a funeral today I
did yeah damn way to bring it down so
fast dude what do you mean that's a good
thing what yeah celebration of life
unless you're one of those glass half
empty Senoritas
stop being so negative what
what wants to die
sneaking out to go to Disneyland is that
what it was that's what it was was there
anything different or unique about this
one
yeah it wasn't my dad so it's pretty
cool
this is actually pretty cool I'm really
glad I went okay so this one ironically
is uh for my dad's brother
and it was the brother that he was the
closest with oh yeah so there are seven
brothers and sisters and um the last two
was my dad and his brother so they kind
of grew up as the two little baby
brothers and uh they were the closest in
the whole family because the the oldest
sister and the oldest brother they're so
far apart they were almost like the
second mom and dad how much far
almost like 20 30 years oh [__] yeah it
was it was crazy oh what that's massive
yeah it's like seven you know so it's
like like this one when this one we
could still be a year apart like that
doesn't tell us any type of math oh you
know what sure octo mom because there
should have been nine this should have
been nine that's why they started
[__] way early so that's why they
started [__] way earlier they started
[__] way early what's the difference
the tone yeah
yeah
so I don't know if English we did we
never had a funeral for my pops because
of the way he went so I just felt kind
of weird and I was never really tight
with like uh like that side of the
family because my dad didn't really like
pull this together for some reason
um so I don't know if I'm taking it this
way
um like they're trying to have two
funerals in one but every like um person
that went up to go speak
about
my dad and my uncle almost as one which
is cool because they for the family they
had the same Mission like um my dad and
his brother were the first to flee
communist China to go to Hong Kong they
were the first to help bring all the
family over to Hong Kong and then when
they came to America they're the ones
that sponsored each one to come and
every step of the way they made
um money and would send it back to the
family because they didn't really have
like enough money to like for like food
and shelter and stuff like that so when
they said stories like
um like my uncle's name is James like
they weren't like oh you know so this
I'm really grateful for James whatever
they always say like I'm really grateful
for my uncles and then they know they're
talking about fourth and fifth Uncle
which is my dad and then all of them
would say like that they're like you
know it's so cool to have my own clothes
so it was cool like they I don't know if
they're trying to like
have one funeral in their mind or
because they didn't really have the
other one or if that was just
historically what happened to you so
it's cool to hear all these things from
that perspective
because I have my own perspective of my
dad like for example one story that they
said was it was my
um one of my oldest cousins who's almost
my mom's age she was saying in China
they were so poor that like she almost
never saw her mom because her mom was
working all the time and so he she
remembers my dad and my fourth Uncle
always
um taking her to the park babysitting
and doing all that stuff and taking her
to go buy food and buy snacks and buy
desserts and so she never felt like she
was poor even though they were crazy
poor because they would split all the
money and then it comes come to find out
later on that was when my dad and the
uncle was like 14 and 15 and they were
[__] the shithaulers like they were
[__] the [__] out
which was kind of fun
so like when everyone found out they
were pissed they were so mad no one was
madder than the [__] yeah like
you've been [__] us
so they didn't have
um like [__] hauler they didn't have
irrigation so people would go from like
Village to Village packing those carts
full of [__] and then my dad and the
uncle would do that
um graveyard shift to make money at 14
and 15. the whole [__] and then they
would go and then pay and then buy
snacks and stuff so like as my cousin
was saying this I was like damn this
would have been so cool to know I didn't
know like these stories like that but
what's the one that your dad did tell
you
well he was eight how poor was he
so this is the part like my dad would
always tell me these things he would he
would tell me stories and he would
always tell me stories but then I'm like
I don't know if he's saying it in a
certain way that makes me focus on the
wrong parts so now he said it yeah he'll
be a genetic thing
you don't even understand man we were so
poor like I couldn't even afford
cigarettes when I was eight years old
you're like and I was like wait you're
smoking or eight he goes no I couldn't
afford cigarettes bro
[Laughter]
did he ever give you an answer like when
he started smoking no you know when
you're a kid you're just like it comes
out the womb right how poor he was yeah
you missed the point
yeah I would just hear it and I'm like
oh [__] he's like really poor but then
it's not until later you're like wait
what six you start with her six how old
are you oh man yeah man so he loved the
funeral yeah great here are all these
other stories from people and then uh uh
of other parts of my dad because I still
have questions as to like how it
happened why it happened the
relationships how come you didn't leave
a note he didn't leave a note with me he
didn't leave a note with his best friend
brother that's the first person I texted
when it all happened so a lot of things
are still questions in the air
um but it was cool to kind of just get
answers I never was looking for but I
feel like makes the story more full and
and helps me understand the person well
if he had answers I mean
where it is
did he say something to you like Circuit
City
yeah you want to return something you
can't damn it do they have this in stock
they don't damn it there's no way for me
to check I got this receipt 1999 still
did didn't you say that you're uh is
this the brother that he said something
to you I think when your dad passed
didn't he like give you some kind of
advice about it yeah so he was the one
when I told uh he was one of the first
people I talked I was like Hey I Just
Wanna let you know uh my dad passed and
and then he was like what how I'm like
well he did it to himself and the first
thing he texts because I thought he'd be
pissed what the [__]
um but he was like
um I just want to let you know the last
couple of months he's been coming over a
lot we've been talking and he's just a
very very stubborn person and no matter
what I couldn't
um help him see any other perspective
so
um whatever type of energy that you have
that's trying to figure things out
because like don't don't blame yourself
don't do anything like that just Channel
it and give it to the next Generation
wow so it's not Uncle yeah uncle's it's
good advice yeah it's super cool dude
that's really dope to speak on
Generations yeah yeah that's how that's
how he sees the game you know that's
cool that's how he sees like the long
game right yeah yeah but your eyes I saw
the generation because you guys were
just playing NBA Jam and he's still in
that mode
come on
pass me the ball okay
he's a point guard of the family that
guy
[Laughter]
but the point God
so yeah was it a ton of your family
there today like a bunch of people that
you don't normally see yeah like people
have never nine percent of them were
yeah yeah especially like she's been
with me for [__] like 50 years 15
years and she's seen some of them maybe
one or two I just saw two his wife and
his daughter that was it yeah that's how
that's how little my dad like pulled us
together so there's cousins I haven't
seen in 20 years
um just imagine like seeing a bunch of
guys that look just like Barbara one's
got glasses
it's like Flanders family reunion like
that [__] one sort of hard hat
even the women look exactly like you
oh [__] I was there though I was like
dude there's like a quan family look
there whoa
whoa look at the look
Rose and the eyes like this part like in
the head like it I'm like you
[__] are related for sure I
remember seeing your dad for the first
time at barbell and I didn't know he was
your dad and I was like I bet that's
Bar's bad
why I just I got a feeling bro I got a
feeling he really does and he kind of
Walks Like Him and I was like that guy
kind of Walks Like Bart and then his mom
looks he looks exactly like his mom too
oh like half and half like I don't know
it's just like the Quan family look is
so strong that like there's in-laws and
stuff so like if you place them all
together it looks like okay all of these
people are related and then some of them
are slightly varied because this person
married this person and this person
married this person yeah but like you
could like throw all of us that was
there in a room and then like this is
the Venn diagram middle part
[Laughter]
would you say you learned way more about
your family through this one funeral
alone yeah I would say so because like
everyone came up and tell personal
stories and then
um they did like a cool like is that
what they were saying
oh it's all in all
all mainly Cantonese I thought they were
praying the whole time mainly Cantonese
so I didn't even know half of it and
then the other half when they started
speaking to Mandarin I'm like oh okay
and then the the English one spoke the
least that was a functions
could barely know anything
yeah oh yeah how did Tiger feel about it
because it was this dude because this is
his first time
oh
so like he just learned so I just
started talking to him about kind of
religion a little bit
um and I was explaining you know I was
trying to like explain to Heaven and
Hell a little bit and then also just
trying to like say like more of the
Buddhists of like things like everything
kind of has a soul so he's like really
pissed at hell and like really about
like heaven so right now you just
learned about Abraham Lincoln so he's
like the person that shot Abraham
Lincoln for sure is in hell right Mom
I'm like wow maybe
[Laughter]
so we're kind of in that headspace with
him
so as soon as we walked in he was like
he's like is that is that Papa's uncle
and I'm like oh [__] it's Papa's Uncle
for sure and he was just asking question
after question like okay so his body's
there right but then what about like I
thought he was supposed to go in heaven
is he going to hell and he's saying all
this stuff out loud and I'm like no dude
not right now just put a mic on him
listen up listen up this kid's got a
point one man show he asks the same
[__] question over and over but keeps
replacing the newer words he learns so I
took like this um I'll go like is that
is that someone in the rectangle who's
that someone and then say uh that's your
uncle that's your uncle is that the
uncle and the rectangle
uncle in the casket he'll say this by 30
times just replacing it with more
accurate words but I'm like you got it
the first time can I say yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes he just wants to learn his
vocabulary
well because we're trying to like yeah
yeah so everyone's like
is that the person that direct my uncle
in my casket what happens when you
update without rebooting just imagine
trying to process that as a kid like not
knowing what like loss is or anything
you're just trying to you're just there
for what it is kind of cool yeah
you have to explain like the the whole
ritual and everything huh dude yeah
bearing like so it was the casket
what do you alley-oop the casket
I'm sorry yeah and then the pastor says
boom shakalaka yeah
no and he was like can I go over there
can I see I'm like no dude chill because
everyone's like still crying
is there any like when it's a Taiwanese
funeral is there anything super
different than just like a average
American Funeral so that part I was like
I I didn't find out about your family
that you didn't know anything about
because all the things that he was
saying about your dad I was like my dad
would never tell me anything about his
family either well uh so like I think if
I were to go through a similar
experience I'd be like yeah because when
I went there the part that was weird was
like so I was like
um I'm like is my dad the only one that
didn't bring the family together so I
would go there and I'm like I see like
extended family right like it's not like
like there's a bunch of kids that are
like 20 something and then they see each
other and they're immediately talking
about the storm they were they were like
oh so you guys might have been the odd
ones out I was like okay so everyone
here hangs out and then uh they were
picking up on conversations except for
us
so I'm like maybe my dad was the only
one that did a bad job of bringing
together because uh their seven brothers
and sisters and then it seemed like
like 90 of them all were all like they
know they're all cool they're all caught
up yeah and they never reached out to
you personally like how did your dad
know and I understand why so I think I
would be more it's I think I'd put it
more on my dad because if you know like
let's say
um your brother divorced his wife right
because my parents are divorced it's
like I don't want to pry too much you
know so it'd be up to the dad to go it's
on him well you should be involved in
both families your mom's side and the
dad's side that's how I that's how I see
it makes sense because I could totally
see like
um uh like my older cousins that like
they're like oh well I'll just ask like
Paul then because I don't want to just
go and then cross because they're
already divorce I don't know it's like
who has custody like it's just like a
lot of it's a complicated situation here
you know so what kinds of things were
people saying to you personally when
they walk up to you to say hi like yeah
are they like are they like I've been
watching JK a lot of them have though
shrimp dude dude we got a [__]
networking family dude remember that guy
networking oh you gotta like that's a
[__] I've never seen in my
entire life never seen in my entire
[__] life I barely know his wife who
the last time I met her was [__]
25 years ago in China oh [__] so I bet
so I'm like this is the second time me
seeing her yeah 25 years later and then
we're eating and then he come here hey
you you make a youtube
hey can you can you make this guy a
YouTube video and then I'm like uh who's
that he go oh you know my Michael you I
mean I don't know I don't know Michael
you I know Michael you why didn't you
tell me is my he's my client I'm like
I'm like your client I'm like what are
you just scoring points so I I fix
computer there's nothing that cool it
has nothing nothing I make YouTube
videos like do you own a marketing
agency or like I was like wait so here's
your client I'm like what do you do for
him he goes I fixed his computer and
then I'm like okay that's it yeah then
he's like can you help him he needs more
customers and I'm like he's just a nice
guy
for sure he's watching this going I
don't sound like that
so then he gets his information now he's
like can I text you and Bart kept saying
like I'll just give you my email and he
goes oh okay and he waited and he like
did some [__] on his phone he's like oh
uh do you mind if I call you a email I
can't believe I'm doing that because I
shouldn't do this
I'll fully do it
he tries a little bit come on let's see
it for a minute let's move it on let's
get some information and then yeah and
then he walks away and then he just
starts eating and like doesn't have
another exchange with Bart at all until
I think something else Dawns on them and
then he walks back up over there and he
like told you he's like oh so you got
the information right no then he was
like he showed me like I guess his mood
board he's like video like this okay
like all right
his video inspo dude and the whole time
actually after lunch like people I
haven't met before that I'm like okay
cool like they speak English or that
speak Mandarin I'm trying to have small
talks I want to connect so Laura those
are your kids I'm like how old are they
no other 10 I'm looking cool what about
you and we're like talking and then that
guy is just quiet the whole time just
eating
like you make YouTube video
and I'm like what the [__] no
smoke or anything no report straight to
it yeah just straight to it maybe he
doesn't feel as connected you know to
like everybody oh that guy they don't
even ask me for favors I know exactly
that's like too nice dude yeah you put
up with that [__] kid okay you make him
a YouTube video yeah you make him give
him
give him the info yeah this is the real
I'm gonna CCU in that email all right
whatever I was like this guy actually
makes videos
straight to the trash
I feel like when you meet family that
you've never met before they don't even
feel like you're they're your family it
just feels like strangers that look like
you or have your genetics my regular
family feels like that for me
why is that you know like we're related
but we don't we feel like strangers
because you don't have any experiences
together like you feel like that with
your brother
with all my family like my immediate
like my brothers and sisters like we're
so different like I feel like I'm such
an odd one out
um it's her parents also didn't do like
a good job of like
you guys are brothers and sisters uh
reinforcing the relationship [__]
Warrior handshake ever I think a lot has
to do with the parents to be honest yeah
yeah that's true because you are taking
it from them yeah because if you're like
the type of pair like let's say two kids
like are arguing they're like all right
both of you guys are [__] are in
trouble
[Laughter]
all right you guys have to [__] all
right
[Laughter]
remember what I was saying earlier
here's the rest in trouble don't let me
finish man
thank you
foreign